spider-man homecomings biggest stars or
Hollywood veterans but the film is
easily the youngest cuing spider-man
film ever made the story surrounds Peter
Parker and a crowd of fresh-faced
characters that includes Michelle played
by 20 year olds and daya Coleman an
actress and singer known professionally
as just zendaya if you feel like you've
seen zendaya before you're probably
right she's been pretty busy over the
last few years earning increasingly
higher profile roles so now is the
perfect time to familiarize yourself
with the former Disney star who's
turning heads in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe shake it up if you know zendaya
from anywhere it's either those X out
skincare commercials or the musical
sitcom shake it up that ran from 2010 to
2013 on the Disney Channel in her
breakout role as rocky blue she starred
alongside Bella Thorne Cece Jones as
background dancers on a local dance
series a big hit for the channel shake
it up also spawned several music videos
turning zendaya and thorn into household
names at least in households including
preteen girls with an affinity for
Disney frenemies along with starring and
shake it up zendaya and thorn also
anchored the 2012 Disney Channel
made-for-tv movie frenemies comprised of
three intertwining stories about the
misadventures of teens who are feuding
with everyone from their best pal to
their pet dog viewed by more than 4
million people upon its premiere the
film proved there was plenty of demand
for zendaya outside her hit series her
debut album the same year shake it up
ended its run zendaya stepped out as a
solo artist releasing her self-titled
debut LP through Disney's music imprint
Hollywood Records although the album
wasn't a blockbuster hit it performed
respectively peaking at number 51 on
Billboard and earning critical praise
from outlets like Allmusic who deemed it
a streamlined self-assured first effort
you may have caused in day of promoting
the record during it Today Show
appearance in 2013 performing her top 40
hit replay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't see you anywhere go Zack zendaya
got a chance to headline her own Disney
Channel original film in 2014 with
zapped which tells the story of a teen
who realizes her phone is suddenly able
to control all the boys at her school
Zee ninis ensues of course but India's
character eventually learns a valuable
lesson about how to treat people the
broadcast gave the budding star another
hit for the channel it was viewed by
nearly 6 million people following its
premiere ending up as the most-watched
cable broadcast of the night bad blood
she's made plenty of her own music
videos as a Disney starlet but in 2015 s
and Deum made a high-profile cameo for
another artist Taylor Swift in Swift's
bad blood videos and Dale plays a
character called cutthroats and if
you're among the millions who saw the
star-studded clip in 2015 it might be
one reason you thought she looked
familiar and spider-man homecoming
blackish in 2015's India appeared in
ABC's hip dramedy series blackish as a
guest star in the episode daddy's day
her character Rashida complicates an
emotional tug of war between Dre and his
daughter Zoey though she was obviously a
known commodity thanks to her Disney
Channel tenure this blackish role put
the young star in front of a whole new
group of potential fans outside of the
Disney bubble Casey Undercover after
sharing the spotlight and Shake It Up's
India took center stage in her own
Disney Channel sitcom with KC Undercover
which premiered in 2015 zendaya plays
genius high school student KC Cooper who
learns her parents are actually spies
and they want to recruit her for the
last time
who are you I'll never talk my name is
Katie Cooper and I'm a 60 year old
government spy and although it might
have seemed like a bit of a step back to
return to her Cable roots just as her
big-screen career was poised to take off
she definitely had some compelling
reasons as India told Marie Claire a big
reason why I wanted to come back to
Disney is because I saw a lack of
diversity on the channel to see a black
family to see a young girl with these
adorable afro puffs little things like
that are so important all night
today is good luck streak with music
video cameo appearances continued in
2016 when she was asked to film apart
for Beyonce's all night
aside from the thrill of working with a
global superstar she claims she'd been
obsessed with since birth today had told
people she felt like she got to be a
part of music history on the shoot which
helped round out the visual album
Beyonce crafted for her acclaimed
lemonade LP as of now it's been watched
more than 47 million times an impressive
number even when you put it alongside a
worldwide box-office smash like
spider-man homecoming thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]